ます 今日は心のこの自分を騙してしまうその機能についてお話しさせていただきます
で このテーマは本当はリピートなんですけど
ですから 前のかなり前なんですけどね
同じテーマで話をしたんですから
その話を聞いた方々にとってはまた面白くないと思われるかもしれませんし
それからこのテーマっていうのは
この一般の方々向けの話ではないんです
で 心のこの 騙す機能というかね
これ セルフディシーリングというセルフディセプションという
自分で自分を騙す機能なんですね
そういうのは心にあるんですね
それは一般の仏教の話では
まず言わないことになっているんです
これ言いにくいんです
大変な怖いことになっちゃうんですね
言ってしまえば ですから
この話はこの仏典の中でもかなり内緒話で
この厳密に修行する方々によく注意するために
ほんの僅かにある一か二か章でしか書いてないんです
だから 一般的なパーリ語を読まれる方々でも見つからないと思います
一般の経典の中ではそんなに派手に明確にわかるようにしてないんです
ですから これ逆に私にしたっても
すごい話しにくいテーマなんですね
で この騙す機能というのは
うん 結構一般の方々の心は混乱してしまうという恐れもあります
まあとにかくあの 気をつけてしゃべってはみますけど
全部まとめて今日でお話はできないと思いますけど
あの テキスト 1 冊全部その辺で書いてますからね
で 私ではないんですが
ものすごい大長老が 1 冊まとめて
この騙す機能について書いている本がございまして
そのだいたいその本の内容を中心にしてお話しします
で あの この 騙す機能というば
まあ騙すことは普通ありますね
人に騙されちゃったと
それは良くないということは誰でも知ってるし
まあ人に騙されないようにどうすればいいかという話は一般的には喋れます
だからずっとそういう話を私はしているんですね
やっぱりまあ あまり騙されないようにしてくださいと
でも あまりにも騙されないように注意しちゃうと
またかえって 性格がね
悪くなってしまう可能性もあります
人の話は話には全く耳を向けないわがままな人間になる可能性もあります
簡単に騙される人間というのは
またもう人の話にすぐ乗ってしまいますからね
それも良くないし だからといって人に騙されないように頑張ってしまっちゃうと
結局頑固な人の話には全く耳を向けない人間にもなってしまっちゃいますね
ですから やっぱりそこら辺でこのどうすればいいかという中道的なところを見つからなくちゃいけないんですね
人の話も聞かなくちゃいけない
だからといって 何でも鵜呑みにしてもいけないし
その両方なんですね ですから
自分の判断能力も使う必要もあるし
自分一人で能力判断能力ない場合は
知識人の話をよく聞いて
それを使用してその通りに判断してみる必要もありますね
それは日常生活の生き方はそういうふうな生き方でなければいけません
そこら辺でも我々はかなり弱いんです
普通の方々っていうのは
すぐ人の話に乗せられてしまいます
あるいは全く人の話は聞かないと
これ どちらかの極端に入ってしまってるんですね
自分で判断しなさいと言ったら
まあなかなかできなくなって
あるいは大変大胆な悪い判断してしまったりする場合もあるし
人の話も聞きなさいと言ったら
何でも他人に 決まってもらいたいというふうな弱い人間になる可能性もありますからね
そこら辺もやっぱり正しく生きてほしいんですけど
今日はそのところの話ではないんです
他人に騙せないようにではなくて
この自己の騙しきのこのセルフデセプションという
まあそれをちょっと誤解する
英語の単語も誤解するかもしれませんだけど
セルフディフェンスではないんです
自己防衛ではないんです
自分で自分をディシーフ騙すという
で それはどういうことでしょうかね
あの 私たちはだいたい人に騙されちゃうと
かなり気が立っちゃうんですよ
あの人に騙されたと あの人に裏切られたと
あの人は約束破ったと
そういうふうに他人については
我々はかなりきつい条件をつけちゃうんですね
だから人に対してはきちんと約束を守りなさいと
で 言うことをちゃんとしなさいと
人を騙すなよとかね 信頼できる人間になりなさいと他人に向かって我々は激しく言うんです
そこで騙されたところで
ものすごく落ち込んだり
あるいは気が立ったり
怒ったりはします そういうことは一見
なんかいいんではないかなと
この社会はこんな遊びはできませんと
この社会ではしっかりと約束を守らなくてはならないんだと
商売も生きることもできなくなるんだと
正直でなければ 約束を守らなければ
決まりを守らなければ
そういうしっかりできている社会に生きているんではないかなと
とは思いがちですけどね
でも 本当の心の状態を見てみると
自分でも自分が何者かとわからないんです
ですから よく仏典でからする言うならば言えるのは
あなたはあなたのことを知ってますか？と
あるいは簡単に人に聞いてみると
あなたはどういう性格の人間でしょうかと
自分に聞いたならば 自分にしっかりと言えますかね
私はこのような性格の人間です
私の性格はこういう性格ですとハッキリと言えますか
だって自分のことでしょ
これ なかなか大変だと思いますけど
あなたは何者ですか？という質問に答えられないんです
人に聞けば あなたはもう真面目な人間ですか？あるいはいい加減な人間ですか
？あるいはかなり努力する頑張り屋さんですか？あるいは怠け者ですか？まあいろいろ性格はありますからね
そんな風に聞いても答えられますかね
これすごい真剣な話なんです
あなたはどんな人間ですかと聞いたら答えられますか？というよりれば
What type of man are you? What type of person are you? で答えられますかと
自分のパーソナリティ
人格性について それ自分のことも知らない
悪いには 我々は堂々と人のことを堂々と言うでしょう
あの人は怠け者だ あの人はもうかなり感情的やと
あの人はちょっとヒステリータイプだと
あの人はやっぱり信頼できないんですよ
そうやって人の性格についてはいくらでもレッテルを貼る
それで人格分析とかテキストまでやりますよ
あのパーソナリティのね
まあ分析についてかなり本までやります
あれはすべて他人の性格の分析なんです
ですから あれでいいんですかね
自分が何者かともわかってないのに
自分にはあの人が頑張り屋かとか
あるいは怠け者で怠け者かどうか判断できますかと
人のことは全く 心の働きというのは大体そんな簡単に判断できないんです
で この前の話の時でも
私はこのある一つのエピソードを言ったんです
あのあるお坊さんが私に言った話で
昔昔の昔の話でね あの
昔いたってのもそんな昔ではなくて
まあこのこのあるお坊さんがこの田舎で
このあの その人の友達の話でしたけどね
学校で教先生仕事をやってるんですね
それで学校というのは早く終わりますから
まあ学校終わったら そのお坊さんがお寺に戻って
まああるいは散歩していたみたいですね
お寺で そこで そこら辺の村人そのお坊さんがもうまあずっと行ったり来たり
行ったり来たり 行ったり来たり
散歩しているのは見たんですね
あるおばあさんがそれを見ていて
あのお坊さんが真面目に修行しているんだとかね
で見ているんですね ありがたくて
学校も仕事終わって帰ってから時間を無駄にしないで
よく瞑想しているんだとか思っていて
それでその歩きながら
お坊さんいきなり飛び飛び上がったみたいですね
パッと 飛び上がってまだ歩いているんですね
そこで見ていたおばあさんが考えたんですね
おそらくこのお坊さんが瞑想して
うまくいって自分が悟っているかないかと確かめたかもしれません
いわゆる空を飛べるかないかと
そう思っている人々いますよ
悟ったら空を飛べるんだと
それは別の話 そんな話したら時間なくなりますからね
だったらみんな悟っていることになりますけどね
で それですごくありがたくなっちゃって
やっぱりこれは確かめなくちゃいけないんだと思って
あのお坊さんのところに行って挨拶をして
あの先生 あの ちょっと飛び上がったんだけど
あれはどういうことでしょうかと聞いたら
あのお坊さんが ああ おばあちゃん
あれはね 私はこの歩いている時は自分の子供の頃を思い出したんだと
子供の頃を思い出して
それでみんなとこの野球やってたんだと
ガキが子供たちと一緒に
それであの 投げてきた球が自分の体にぶつかりそうになったんです
それで自分が飛び上がって球をよけたんだと
で そういう話をしたんだそうですね
ですから そのお坊さんがただ妄想の中に妄想しながら
子供の自分の子供の頃をね
妄想しながらただ歩いてただけなんですね
でも それを見ていたおばあちゃんにとっては
それはまた違う解釈なんですね
真面目に修行しているんだと
もうそろそろ悟るでしょうと
そうやって人のことわからないんですね
おばあちゃんが聞いて聞いて聞いたのは良かったんですけど
もし聞かなかったならばどうなるんですかね
すると あのお坊さんはすごい立派な人というふうな
もう話が進んじゃうでしょうね
ですから この人の心っていうのは
それで我々にとってはすごい面白い話で
ただ弾を避けただけですよと
ボールを避けただけですよということで
面白く喋ってますけどね
だからこの他人の心さえも
自分の心さえも読めないんだから
他人の心もなかなか読めない
他人の性格もなかなか言いにくいんですね
わかりにくいんです それでよくあることは
例えば私が怒りっぽい人間か優しい人間かと聞いてもわかりません
どういうことかというと
まあみんな親切で みんな親切で
自分の気持ちに逆らうこともなく仲良くしてくれるんだったら
私も親切なんですね 私はみんなとすごい仲良くしているんです
それでみんな私に邪魔をする
いじめる 攻撃する で バカにする
その場合は何でしょうかね
その場合は私も攻撃返す
怒る ですから 私に聞いても
あなたは親切な人ですか？怒りっぽい人ですか？と言ってもわからないんです
それはその条件によって
その条件の中で反応するだけ
時々すごい元気そうな力強そうな人々いるでしょうね
でも何か起きたら全部
もう全部もう何もできなくなっちゃって
落ち込んじゃって 布団から立ち上がれない状態まで落ち込む時もあります
今まであなた元気でみんなに頑張りなさい
頑張りなさいと言ってきたのに
今何も 何でしょうかと聞きたくはなるぐらいになっちゃいます
ですから この我々の心っていうのは
そう簡単にわかるものじゃない
別に複雑というわけじゃないんです
ただ その時 その時の環境に反応するだけ
いわゆる反射人間だけなんです
それ大したことじゃないんです
みんな赤色を着ているんだったら
じゃあ私も赤色を着るぞとなるだけのことで
みんな髪の毛真っ赤に染めたならば
いやまあ見る人は髪の毛真っ赤に染めている
じゃあ私もということになるだけに
それで深い意味があります
全然何もないんです ですから
この人間やっていることにはほとんど何も深い意味がないんです
ただ反射人間で 行動しているだけのことなんです
だから そういう人に聞いたっても
あなた何者ですかとわかるわけないでしょうに
ただ反射的に生きているだけなんですね
ですから 心は別にそんな複雑なものではないんですし
ただ反射しているだけ
人にちょっと失礼なことを言われたら
いきなり怒りで燃え上がる
褒めてもらったらものすごく喜んで舞い上がっちゃう
ただそれだけ で こちらがすごく丁寧に挨拶をして
大変丁寧な敬語でお話しすると
向こう側も同じレベルで返してくれる
それで私がこの人は大変丁寧な行儀の良い人だよと私のメモに書いておいたっても
それは間違いであって
ただその時の反応だけなんですね
大体の人間っていうのはそうやってこのまあ
ただ反射人間なんですね
だから反射人間だから
私はこれから怒るか笑うか
泣くか 人を褒めるか人をけなすか
人を助けるか人を殴るかわからないんです
どちらでもあり得るんです
ですから 今日まで何も悪いことをしなかった人が
明日とんでもない犯罪を起こす可能性はあります
それで犯罪 いろいろ悪いことばっかりやっていた人が
またものすごく自分を直して立派に真面目に生きている可能性もあります
ですから 正しく仏教的な立場で言うならば
我々はできるだけ人間にラベルを貼って
この人はこういう人間だよと
この確定することはやめた方が生きやすいんです
人にラベルを貼って 悪人
善人 善人 怒りっぽい人
怠け者 頑張る人 そういうふうにラベルを貼らない方がいいんです
そのラベルを貼ったら
そのラベル自体が変化しないでしょうに
固定になるでしょうに
だから固定した人格がないと思った方が
人間関係はうまくいくんです
それは暗い話じゃないんです
人格固定していないんだから
どうったことないんだから
変えようと思えば変えられるし
もっと悪くさせようと思ったら悪くすることもできます
もう決して犯罪を起こさない
例えば子供がいるとしますね
いとも簡単に犯罪する人に育てることはできますよ
何のこともない とても簡単です
ですから 悪い言葉で言えば
人のことを信頼しない方がよろしいし
逆に自分のことも絶対自分では信頼しない方がいいです
で それは悪い言葉で言えばそういうことなんですけど
優しい言葉で言えば まあそんなに
あの 何といいますか 感情的になって舞い上がって
ああ びっくりしたとかね
そんな必要ないんです
たとえ自分の子供でも
もうなんか隣の あの 何といいますか
店の窓ガラスを割って帰ったんだからといってね
なんでとんでもないことをするんだ
びっくりした もう本当にもう
そんなもう混乱しなくてもいいんです
そんなことはあり得ることだからね
旦那さんがちょっと浮気しただけで
もう自殺したいほど混乱するでしょうに
どうったことないんで
そんなことは 旦那様 そういう性格で
奥さんもなかなか負けない性格でしょうに
ですから この人のことばっかり固定した人格が欲しくて生きることはよくないんですね
あなた 昔はすごく優しかったんではないか
私のことをすごくかわいいかわいいって言ってくれたんではないかと言って
55歳になったおばちゃんが旦那さんをいじめると言ったって意味がないでしょ
そんなことで ですから
この結婚するときは この人
私のことをものすごく大事にしてくれるんだと
だから一生この人と一緒になるんだと思っても
まあ 2 3週間でもう大事にしないようになってしまう可能性もあるし
あるいは大事にしてもらう可能性もある
どっちかわからないんです
40年間夫婦仲良くしても
41年目でもう全部壊れてしまう可能性もあります
そういう何が起きても驚かない方が智慧の人の生き方なんですね
ああ そう 別れたんですかと
ああ なるほど それで終わっちゃうんです
なぜかというと 人の性格っていうのは
その場でその場でぐるぐる変わるもんなんです
ですからもう 性格っていうのは波に例えてみたら
波っていうのは その時その時の条件で現れるんであって
波には厳密に決まっている形がありますか？決まっている高さ
決まっている形 決まっているリズム
そういうのはないでしょうに
その時その時の条件によって波が激しくなるか
ゆっくりなるか 高くなるか短くなるか
いろいろ ですから 私たちの性格というのは波と同じもので
その時の条件によって反射するだけのことなんです
ですから 最初に言いたいのは
私は私のこともわからない
私には私の性格についても保証はない
ですから 人の性格を見てびっくりしたり
落ち込んだり 混乱したり
舞い上がったりする必要はないんだよと
すごいクールな心で落ち着いて見てみると
うまく生きていられるんです
それまた逆に無知な無気力な生き方じゃないんです
いわゆる理解能力はあるんです
人がある人がいきなり感情的になって
ものすごい感情的になって怒ったりする
そうすると あ なるほど
この人がこういうこういう条件の中で
こういうふうに感情的になって怒っているんだよと
この人が怒ったら ちょっと都合が良くないんだと
と分かった人が じゃあちょっと環境を変えてあげる
ちょっと一言葉で褒めてあげる
褒めてあげたら 今までカンが怒った人は何のことなく笑っちゃうでしょうに
何のことなく笑っちゃう
ですからまあ 人間関係っていうのはうまくこのはかどれるんです
この我々は人に固定した性格を与えないならば
そこで我々の生き方は何でしょうかね
人が一回だけでも悪いことをしたら
これみんなに言いふらしちゃう
あの人こういうことをしたんだよと
1977年10月11日
もう3時30分あるいは3時3分でこういうことをします
そういう一回一回 一回の何か出来事を覚えておいて
それで永久的にその人を泥棒か犯罪か何かもうレッテルを貼ってあげるんですね
そういう生き方でしょ
ですから 直るにも直らなくなっちゃうんですね
例えば ある強盗した人がいるとしますね
若い頃 何か訳があって強盗してしまうと
それで見つかって それでも取り調べられたとします
それで私たちはその人の人生に影響的に
この人は強盗だとレッテルを貼ってあげる
そうすると 一旦自分の罪を償ってから社会に戻っても
じゃあ仕事を探そうかなと思ったら
裏で誰かでも この人は刑務所で3ヶ月とか見て帰った人ですからね
強盗してね 気をつけてくださいと言っちゃうでしょうに
それで仕事は見つからない
そうすると その人はまた強盗しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
生きて られませんだから
そうやってこの我々は人間に固定した人格を与えてあげて
わざとその他人の生き方をもうそんなふうにしてしまっちゃうんですね
それはすごい残酷ですよ
それでよく社会に見える
もう一つあります これはいい方向を見ればよくイメージあるでしょ
特にこのタレントの人々の世界では
なんとかイメージを作ってそれで生きているんですね
イメージっていうのは
それ一時的な人を面白くするために自分がやることだけで
例えばもうものすごい頭の悪い人のイメージで
もうテレビでウケたならば
一生そのイメージでやろうとする
それで違うキャラクターを見せちゃうと
みんなプロデューサーからみんなそれは機嫌が悪いんですね
だから悪役をやった人が悪役で売れたならば
死ぬまで悪役をやらなくちゃいけないし
恋人役をやって売れた人が死ぬまでその役をやらなくちゃいけないというふうに決まってるんですね
それはまあ 演技の世界でね
演技の世界で実際の生活と言いますから
関係ないんですけど  それでもトラブル起きたりはします
本人がかなりそれで悩んだりする場合もあります
違う演技もやってみたいんだけど
なかなかやってもらわない
ですから この私たちはこのタレントではなくて
どんな人にもそうやってイメージをつけてあげる
あるいは何か性格悪い性格を貼って貼ってあげる
貼ってあげて 自分がやったものだから
ずっとそのままで その人の性格を変えられないようにと頑張っちゃうんですね
それはすごい他人に対してえらい迷惑なんですね
本人に対しては 例えば子供に対して
あなたよく頑張りますね
頭はいいですね 頭はいいですねと言って
みんなにも言いふらしたりして
うちの子はよく勉強しますねと
よく頑張りますよと そんなイメージを作ってあげたら
その人の人格がというかね
まあ壊れるんでしょ それですっごく精神的なストレスたまったりして
で それで人間関係壊れてしまうんですね
それでその人がもし一回だけでも試験うまく点数取れなかったならば
お母さんが怒って そんな風に育てた覚えがないんですよと
子供はバカだから あなたに育てた覚えが一度もないんですよと言い返せばいいんですけどね
みんな自然に育てるもんですからね
母に何もできませんですけど
子供はそこまで頭鋭くないんだから
うぬぼれするんですね
もったいない 申し訳ないことをしたんだと
お母さんが 100点満点取れるように私を育てたんだと
なのに私は今日は 40点だからと
もう無知無茶でしょうね
母親にそんな 100点取れるように子供育てられますかね
ただ食べるものをあげるぐらいのことでしょうね
寝かしてあげる 食べるものをあげる
服を洗ってあげるとかね
それぐらいのことしかやってないのに
ですから この 母親はびっくりする
がっかりする なんであんたもう勉強しないんですか？とかね
それは母親が悪いんで
ああいうふうに何でイメージ作ってあげたんですかと
それで子供でもそのイメージに合わせよう合わせようと努力するでしょうし
でもそれですっごい苦しんじゃうんですね
だから本当のところは
誰にも何の性格もないんです
その場でその場でなんとか反応するだけ
全くの反応して生きているだけなんですね
だから生命として仏教は見ているんだから
猿も犬も人間もほとんど同じことなんです
ただ その環境に応じて反応
反応して生きている たとえカラスでもいじめてみてください
かえって人間をいじめる凶暴な鳥になる
カラスに優しくしてみてください
結構かわいい鳥になってくるんです
ものすごく頭のいい頭のいい鳥で
たまたま何か食べ物でもあげたりしてね
ちょっと話してみてください
よくもその人の顔と声を覚えておいて
すごく親切にしてくれるのです
一番なじみやすい鳥はカラスなんです
鳥の中で頭がいいんですから
でも一般的にはカラスは嫌だとかね
思ってるんだから 確実にカラスも人間に邪魔をする
攻撃をする 巣なんかそこで卵を温めている時はかなりカラス凶暴的でしょ
それはみんな失礼だから
カラスに対して そこでこのカラスの性格を書いている方々も
その時は気をつけてください
カラスはすごい凶暴ですよと
でも 私の個人的な経験で言えば
カラスはそうやって巣で卵も守っていたっても
そこら辺で平気で遊べるんです
自分の国だったら全然気にしない
時々子供たちが木に登ったりするでしょうし
その時は知らないんだけど
上にカラスの巣なんかあるんですね
その時も子供を攻撃しないんです
カラスは 攻撃しちゃったら子供が落ちちゃって大変なことになるでしょうね
で 子供は遊びで木登りしているんだよとわかってるんですね
わかっていると私は見ているんだから
見ていたんだからね カラスは何するんですかと
カラスの母親が来て この前に木の上に座ってキャーキャーキャーキャーキャーと鳴くんですね
鳴くと子供はうるさいということでまた降りたりします
あまりにも激しく鳴くと
もうわかります 子供周り見ると
やっぱりカラスの巣があるんだから心配しているんだと
じゃあ降りましょうと
何のことなく降りるんです
ですから そこら辺はお互いに理解あるんです
そうすると攻撃はなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから だからカラスは凶暴な鳥ですか？親切な鳥です
そんな決まりがないんです
で カラスは人間の言葉をしゃべるということを皆様ご存知でしょう
教えてあげたらすごい綺麗に発音するんです
ですから まあそんなもんなんですね
だから動物でも凶暴にするか親切にするかということは
我々のアプローチ次第で決まってる性格がないんです
この決まってる性格がないんだからこそ
うまく管理できるんです
そこで我々はある間違いをするんですね
カラスは凶暴 決まってるんだ
あなた凶暴にしなさいと
そこで 特に日本の社会はすごい厳しいでしょうね
みんなにラッテルを張ってくれるんでしょうね
迷惑なんですけど 自分で私はこんなものだよというならば
それは自由です いいんですけど
それは認めません 私があなたは何者かと決めますよと
それで決めてくれちゃって
この人は怠け者だ この人は怒りっぽいよ
この人は信頼できないんだとかね
そうやって決めてもらって
それから強引に決めてもらった性格は
私たちは守らなくちゃいけない
いやおうなしに それぐらい精神的ないじめがありますかね
人間にはやっぱり怒鳴りたい時は怒鳴る自由は必要でしょうし
怒りたい時は怒る自由も必要でしょうし
ふざけたい時はふざける自由も必要でしょうし
真剣真面目になりたい時は真剣真面目になる自由も必要でしょうし
だってそれは決まってる性格じゃないんだから
ある環境に行ったらやっぱりふざけたくなる
みんなそうでしょう お祭りとかね
そういうところに なんとなく心が温かくなってきて
踊りたくなる それでも自分が怒りっぽくて気が荒っぽいなと隣からレッテル貼ってもらったならば
たとえお祭りに行ってもみんなこうやって見るんだからね
そうすると自分には楽しむことができなくなっちゃうんですね
あるいは平気で言うんですね
あなたが来たら困りますよと
そんなことないはずでしょうし
ですから どんな人でも
そのその場で真面目になる時もありますし
怠け者になる時もありますし
ふざける時もありますし
真剣に頑張る時もあります
それはそのその場で現れる反応のみなんですね
そこを理解しておけば
我々にとってはかなり人生として生きやすいということがあるんです
問題っていうのはかなり解決しやすい
あの聖書でもね すごい厳しく言ってます
人を判断するなよと 判断すること自体罪として書いてますけど
まあ仏教はあんまり人気ないのはわかりますけど
キリスト教でいえばかなり派手に人気あるでしょうね
でもみんな平気で人を判断する
判断してはいけないと書いてますけどね
そういうことですから
結局私たちは私たちのことはわからない
人に聞いても あなたこれからいつ奥さんと喧嘩しますか？と聞いてもわかりますかね
次の夫婦喧嘩はいつでしょうか？と聞いてもわからないでしょうに
いくらその人を責めても
あなたはね ちゃんとあなたでしょうに
喧嘩するのは ですから
次の夫婦喧嘩の時間言ってくださいと
そんなこと言っても誰もわからない
その条件によって夫婦喧嘩になるかならないかということになってしまいます
ただそれだけのことなんです
そういうことで この騙す機能っていうのは
まあそんなもんでもないんです
このこれから騙す機能について喋りますけど
全部喋る時間はないと思いますけど
あれ 自分が自分を騙すんだからハッキリしたことがあるんです
自分でわからない 例えば自分でわかってインチキやってる場合は騙す機能じゃないんです
それわかってないことは必要な条件なんです
例えばこういう人がいますね
あのよく良いことをする
みんなに対して親切 でもその人知ってます
そう いろいろ良いことをしておけば
みんなにちょっと親切に振る舞っておけばね
自分の立場が安全だと
だって自分のお客さんでしょうしね
私の店で物を買ってくれるんだと
本当は私の品物はちょっと高いんだけど
それでも私のところに来て買ってくれるんだと
だからちょっとわがまま言われたっても
ものすごく親切にしてあげるんだと
そうすると その人は人に対しては親切
でも本人がそれは偽善であることはちゃんと知っています
だから本人あれ騙しているわけじゃないんです
本人がちゃんと計画通りにやっていることで
自分が儲かりたい お客さんが自分のお客さんがもう自分を離れないようにしておきたい
そちらなるのは自分が儲かりたいという気持ちだけ
じゃあ儲かるためにどうすればいいんですか？だったら品物を買い来たならば
もうなんとかご褒美もあげましょうと
おまけもあげましょうと
一回二回ちょっと損したってもいいんじゃないかと
例えば  2 3 千円の品物を買ったら
また千円の品物が まあせっかくだから今日もこれもあげますから持って行ってくださいとかね
それで何か余分にあげたりする
そうすると 買った人もやっぱりこんなことくれちゃったら
この店の人には何のプロフィットはないでしょうとかね
心配したりもします それで次から次へとその店に行く
まあそれであの損がなく
その店が得するようになるでしょうに
そうやって計画立ててやることは騙す機能ではないんです
いわゆる偽善であることを
インチキであることを自分でしっかりと覚悟しているならば
これではないんです だからこれは一般の方々にはなかなかあの
関係ない話なんです ですから
わかりやすく言えば 自分が偽善であることさえにも気づかないことなんです
それが自分を騙す機能なんです
そうでなきゃ騙されてないでしょうに
騙されてるっていうことははっきり騙されてることなんです
完璧に ですから この今日喋ろうと思う
まだまだ喋ってないんですけど
努力しているテーマの場合は
このまるっきり本人には気づかない
どう頑張っても気づかない
ですから それ言っては絶対いけません
バレても 言っちゃうと向こうはものすごい凶暴的になって攻撃して
で 結構私もそういう失敗したことがあります
で いろいろ修行したりするでしょうに
で なかなかうまく進めないとかありますし
それでまあ一生懸命なんで進めない
なんで進めないということでね
で なんとかまあこういうふうに真面目にやっていますけど
うまくいかないんだと
何かないんでしょうか
何か問題ありますかってね
言ったら じゃあ本当はこういうことでしょ？言ったらとんでもないことやって
なんでそんなこと言うんですかって
ものすごく怒って 失礼ではないか
それっきりで仏教までやめてしまっちゃうんですね
大変なんです でもこちらでは知ってますけど
その性格はある限りもう進めないんだと
例えば 自分の欲をしっかりと正当化するために欲をなくす修行をする
そうすると永久的に欲はなくせないでしょ
それでやってもやっても
まあ自分が疲れちゃうし
それで私にもうものすごく希望するんですね
免許を出してくださいと
免許を皆伝しなさいと
こういうことでしょうと
でもなかなかそれはできないし
私にはそんな権利ないんだからね
人はあなたは瞑想進んでるんだよとかね
そんな権利はないんです
あなたは悟ってるんだよとかね
すべて自己証明の世界だからね
人の心にラベルを貼る権利はまるっきりないんです
そんなお釈迦様の教えに逆らって
そんな馬鹿なことをいくら頼んだってやりませんしね
自分の感想は述べますけどね
まあ私から見れば 何々さんがかなり真剣に真面目に頑張ってるみたいと
なかなか進んでるみたいとか
それはあくまでも自分の感想であって
じゃああなたに免許を出しますよと
そんな権利 どこから私にあるんで
みんな平等でしょうね
大体もう真面目に本当に進んでる人だったら
褒めたってもね 放っておきなさいと言うんです
そんなことを 別にあなたに褒めてもらいたくてやってるわけじゃないんだよ
そういうことですから
やっぱりこの修行の世界では大変なことで
これ言ってはいけないことなんですね
言ったらその人がすごく崩れちゃうんですね
壊れてしまいます で なぜ人がそれで混乱して壊れますか？その人悪いんですかね
そうでもないんです 自分を完璧に騙されているんだから
自分にはそれは理解できないだけのことなんです
そこで仏教の世界で このお坊さんたちが一人で修行しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
ですから お釈迦様がすごく心配なんですね
悟ったつもりはとても良くないんです
煩悩なくなったつもりはとても危険なんです
その煩悩なくなったつもり
悟ったつもりを消すために
厳密にものすごい厳しく自己自分の心をチェックする方法っていうのは
もう徹底的に書いてあるんですね
だから そこの世界の中の一部なんです
この騙す機能ということは
じゃあちょっと そこでこういうこともあります
今は騙されてない場合もあります
でもやがて騙されるということがあるんです
そこら辺 すごくややこしいんです
まあ例えば じゃあ本当に仏教はいいこと
ありがたいことで やっぱりこのまあ俗世間でね
いくらやっても意味がないとかね
やっぱり頑張って修行してみるぞと
正直に始まる そこまで騙されてないんです
それでやり始めたら それ途中で
騙す機能が働いてくるということがあるんです
引いてみればね やっぱり大体このこの壁っていうのはみんなにあるんですと思った方がいいんです
わかりやすい例を言います
例えば お母さんが子供に子供をしつけする時あるでしょ
その時 子供がなんでお母ちゃんがそんなに怒ってるんですか？と聞いたら
お母ちゃんの反応はなんですかね
何より私は怒ってないんですよと
全然怒ってないんだと
あれはあなたのために言ってるんだよと
そんなこと言わなかったら
あんた大変でしょうと
全然怒ってないんだよと否定するんですね
本当は怒ってるんです
だから自分が怒ってるかしつけしているかという区別できますか？そこら辺
微妙なところなんですね
例えば 現代時代は自由な世界だよと言って
それで教室の中で子供たちは自分をやりたい放題
自由に勉強したり 勉強しなかったり
いろいろと そこで教師はまあいいんじゃないか
みんなそれぞれ自由で
勉強したい子は勉強する
勉強したくない子はまあそれでいいんじゃないかと
それで先生が自分がすごい現代的で自由に教えてるつもりでしょ
あるいは自分が腰抜けであると
子供に怒鳴って勉強しろよと言える勇気がないと
と言えますかね もし言ったならばどうなるんですかね
先生が あなたは腰抜けやと
この子供たちに怒鳴って
勉強しろよ 冗談じゃないよと
あんた方は勉強好きであろうが嫌いだろうが関係ないんだと
勉強しなかったらただすいませんよと言って
子供に勉強させる勇気がない
腰抜けやと言ったら 先生はすごくそれに怒るでしょ
理屈まで言うでしょ あんたみたいな古い考え方の人々の話を聞きたくないんだと
今の世の中はそういう教育はないんだと
いろんなことを言うんですね
ですから 先生が落ち込めているのは
できた先生だからか 腰抜けだからかと分かりますかね
そこで生徒を怒鳴る先生も
本当に生徒のことを心配して真面目に怒鳴っているか
ただ腹が立って 嫌で やってるかと
これ区別できますかね
まあそういうことだから
このまあそのそこら辺なんです
自分を騙されているということ
そこをいくら騙されないようにしましょうと思ったっても
やがて騙されます その次元次元を乗り越えなくてはならないんです
悟りという我々の場合はね
完全に心清らかになった状態という状態
仮定して仏教は喋ってますから
その状態に至るためには
まあまず荒っぽい怒り
荒っぽい欲 やっぱり私は欲張りやと
じゃあ頑張るぞと やっぱり私はそっち怒るんだと
じゃあ頑張るぞと言って
そうやってこのあの なんて言いますか
隠せて隠れてない あらわになっている貪瞋痴を制御する
そうすると今まで隠れていた貪瞋痴もまあ出てきます
それも制御する あ 私はここまで欲があったんですかとかね
驚いたりしながら そこまでいいんですね
次なんですね 問題は 次に自分がまあよくできたと
もうほとんど煩悩なんかないんだと
もう欲はもう仏教のおかげで
もうほとんど欲張らなくなっちゃったと
仏教のおかげで本当に怒れなくなったと
そこからから危険なんです
この仏教のおかげでよくなったところから
ものすごい危険なんです
そういう人々を見てください
やっていることは何なのかと
もとよりひどいことをやっちゃうんです
もとよりも性格の悪いこと
人を馬鹿にすることとやったりする場合あるんです
本人は気づかないんです
で あの そこからなんですね
問題は だからそうやってこの仏教のために
真理のために 欲をなくすために
解脱のためにと思って貪瞋痴を使う
貪瞋痴でもって行動する
で そういうことでもう騙されています
その壁は誰にでもあります
あの修行過程ではね まあちゃんと報告すると
まあ私は一応あの その対処方法というかね
言わないんですけど 直す方法は言いますけど
大体そういう方々に限って言ってくれないんですね
まあ言ってくれないとこちらも言わないんです
なんか修行の世界 心の働きは私に隠してるなと
隠したって何の意味もない
バカバカしい 隠すってことは隠せませんだからね
人の心は全然隠せません
体は隠せます 私はいつでも言うことだからね
ドアの外から喋ったらわかりません
だから体は簡単に隠せます
でもドアの向こうの人にいて
ても心はわかるでしょうに
だから隠せないものをよく隠しているつもりでね
そうするとやっぱり私も全然わかってない
処理をして じゃあどうぞ頑張ってくださいと
でもそれでずっとその調子に止まっちゃうんですね
言ってもらわない限りは
もう手を出すことは全く不可能
単純なんですけど 全く不可能
言っちゃうともう全部終わり
かえってこちらに攻撃して
何やるかわからなくなっちゃうんです
だから大変単純なことなんですけど
まあまあ ですから お釈迦様はそういうことをよくこういうおっしゃっているんですね
人間というのはね ただ正直でいればそれだけで十分だよと
そんなに偉そうな徳とか徳を積むとかね
善行為をするとかね そんなことはどうでもいいんですから
ただ正直でいればと正直になると
それだけでいいんだと人を育てられますよと
例えばあなた怒っているんだよと言ったら
正直な人だったら気づいてたら
やっぱり怒ったんですねと言うし
でも自分が認めないんだったら正直で言うんですね
でもあなたは怒っていると言っても
私は認めませんねとか
正直ですからね 私は怒っていると認めませんとそう言った人がいいよと
向こうも言ってあげるし
それで正直だから あら
怒りと言ったんだけど
怒ってないと私は思ってはいるんだけど
本当はどうなのかと 自分のことを調べる
調べたら発見する それで人が成長します
ですから 成長したい人に必要な道徳はたった一つ
大量の戒律を守るとかそんなことではないんです
たった 1個 正直ということ
それだけやればもうすごくすごくすべてうまくいきます
はい じゃあそれからほんの少々の時間
本題に入ります 例えば
人間には欲がありますね
そんなことは誰でも知っています
欲があります で 欲があることは何をするかということもだいたい知っています
それで 欲が良くないと
自分ではいくらかは思っているんですね
思っていて 知らないうちにこうなっちゃうんです
自分の欲をどういうふうに正当化して育てればいいかと
本人はわからない それでものすごく
何といいますか 人のことをよく面倒を見る人間になるんです
他人のこと よく他人のために行動する
人のために 世のために頑張っちゃうんです
世のために 他人のために頑張ると
欲のある人にはできることじゃないでしょ
本人もすっごくいい気持ちでいるんです
私はやっぱり他の人と違って
もう自分の人生は人のためにかけているんだと
でも心の中でそれで自分を正当化しているんですね
それで自分が大変喜んで良いことをやっているんだと
良い人間だと 他の人とは違うんだと
いて 他を助けることによって
どんどん物質的に自分を助けてもらうことにしちゃうんですね
自分の立場を安定化させちゃう
自分には仲間がいる 味方がいる
大丈夫です 助けてあげた人々はいくらでもいるんだから
それも一つの投資することと同じで
それで欲消えるわけじゃないんですね
そういう機能があるんです
なかなかこれわかりにくいと思いますけどね
そこで例えば人にものをあげなさいという話がありますね
人にものをあげなさいと仏教で言うのは
ものに対する自分の執着をなくすためなんです
自然法則で何かものを持っちゃうと
それには執着する それはありがたいもの
私のものだと ですから
ものと言えば財産も知識もものなんです
で 社会的な位も立場もものなんです
仏教から見れば ただ 物質だけではないんです
精神的なものもものなんですけど
そうやって自分のものにはとらわれちゃう
嫌なものを買う人がいないでしょうに
花買っても なんでこの花買ってあれ気持ち悪いんだから買いましたよと言う人がいないでしょうに
例えば 私が店に行って女性の服は買わないでしょうに
なんで買ったんだい 着られませんだから
着られないんだから買う人がいないでしょう
だから我々は物を買うと同時に執着があるということは当たり前なんです
食べないものを買う必要はないでしょうに
食べられないものは買う必要はないです
食べるものを買う場合も
自分が食べるものを食べられるもの
自分にとって欲しいものは買うでしょう
勉強するときでも同じことで
自分が好きなことを勉強するんであって
嫌なことを勉強するということはしません
ですから 人間持っている精神的な財産も物質的な財産もすべて欲なんですね
ですから そのものを捨てなさいよ
あげてみなさいと言うと
単純論理で何かに自分が粘り強く執着している
これがやっぱりもう一生大事にするぞと
それでそれはあげてみちゃうと
自分の執着が消えちゃうんですね
だから執着なしにあげることはできないんです
まあ執着がある場合はあげることはできないんですね
あげるためには ものに対する執着をなくさないと
例えば人に 1,000円あげたいんだけど
1,000円私も欲しいんだけど
やっぱりあげたい やっぱり私は欲しいと
だから自分が欲しいと思ったらあげられないんですね
まあしょうがない もう欲しいんだけど
あげますよということで
その 1,000円に対する執着を捨てなきゃあげられない
ですから あげるということは執着を捨てるという心理的な機能
計算してお釈迦様がおっしゃっているものなんです
だから あげればあげるほど
ものにとらわれない心は出てこないと正しい布施にはならないんです
ですが 逆にこういう教えがあるでしょうね
あげることとても良いこと
やっぱり豊かになるのは執着ない人なんですね
なんか自然というのはすごい
なんか意地悪システムなんです
ものが欲しくて 豊かになりたくて頑張っている人は不幸になっちゃうんです
ものにとらわれない人にとっては
いつでもものがうるうる回り回っているんですね
お金 欲しいと思うとお金が逃げちゃうんですね
あってもなくてもどうでもいいやと思う人の周りはもう合理に回ってるんです
そういう法則なら心の法則です
ですから このあげるということをすると
布施ということをしちゃうと
これはいいことだと わかって
そのうわべだけを考えてどんどんあげたりします
人が来たら何かあげたりする
何かもうお土産をあげなきゃ人を帰さないとかね
そういうことにするという人々もいますね
でもそれで その人は何を考えているんでしょうかというと
それでもって違う 違う形の執着を作っちゃうんですね
違う形の執着を作っちゃう
その人 喜んでくれたと
すごい仲良くしてくれるんだと
そうやって違う形の何か自分が獲得しているんです
あげることで そのあげることで何か違うものを獲得しようとしちゃうと
結局執着は薄くなってないんですね
だから複雑で こういうところはすごい複雑なんです
またわかりやすいことを言いましょう
あの恩を知っているというね
やっぱり人から何かやってもらったら
それはよく覚えておかなくちゃいけない
それは仏教では大変な素晴らしいことだと
人が何か自分のために何かやってくれたら
それだけは一生忘れないでくださいと
人の恩は だから人の恩を忘れないことはものすごい素晴らしい性格なんです
それで一番恩深いのは両親なんです
人間にとっては 両親がやってくれる量っていうのは
もう誰もやってくれません
ですから 自分に対しては一番恩があるのは両親でしょうし
それでそれはわかって
じゃあ一生懸命親の面倒を見ましょうと
両親の面倒を見ましょう
そうやってこの一生懸命
自分がこの恩返しの恩返
恩返し 恩返しする人間になる
本当はこの恩返しするんだけど
親の面倒は見る 目上の人々の面倒を見る
それで一生懸命恩返しをする
恩返しをするんだけど
そこら辺でその騙し機能があるんです
どういう騙し機能かというと
あれは結局恩返しじゃないんです
自分が親の面倒を見ることで大変喜んでいるんです
大変満足しているんです
みんな褒めるし 他の兄弟もすごく自分のことを褒めるし
両親ももうざんざん自分のことを褒めるし
喜んでいるし だから両親
親戚 周りの人々 社会の人々
みんな喜ばせて みんなに褒めてもらって
かなり得をしているんです
だから本人が知らず知らず
この恩返しすることから必然的に得られる得に引っかかっているんです
引っかかって恩返しをするんだけど
それでどうなっているかというと
欲が本人を騙しているんです
本人が欲があるとわからない
本人に聞けば いえ 私は別に何のことなく
まあ親が喜んでいるんだから
親の親孝行しているだけですよと
まあ兄弟が兄弟が忙しいんだから
別に兄弟に頼んだっても意味がないし
私が自分でやってますよと
それだけのことですよと本人が思ってますけど
やっぱり裏でこの恩返しすることから得られる得で自分が溺れてるんです
ですから 欲をなくすという機能が働かなくなっちゃうんです
具体的には恩返し行動と行動しています
わかりやすく言えば 別に親孝行したいしたくないかっていう気持ちじゃなくて
親孝行したら親が喜んでくれるんだと
親が喜んでくれるんだからやってますよという気持ちなんです
そうすると あまり正直な気持ちじゃないでしょうね
親が思ってくれるんだから
親が落ち着いてくれるんだから
いちいち文句言わないんだからということで恩返しをする
親孝行する 親孝行は結局はあの本物の親孝行じゃないんですね
いわゆる偽善的な親孝行なんですね
偽善だと自分でわかっちゃったら
もうこの騙し機能じゃないんです
自分でも偽善だとわかってないところは偽善
本当の騙し機能なんです
それからこのまたもう一つ良い性格がありますね
この人の話を聞く 目の上の目上の人の言うことを聞く
例えば 特に子供の場合は
両親の話をよく聞くこと
先生の話をよく聞くことは
聞くことが大変大事なことなんです
これ従うという意味でもないんだけど
なんか似てますけどね
必ず従うという意味ではないんですけど
やっぱりまあ話をよく聞く
言ったことはちゃんとやる
一人で朝起きなさいと言ったら
はい わかりましたと 今日から一人で起きますよと言って
真面目に頑張ると それはあの子供にしたっても
大人の人だっても 大変大事な
良い性格なんです だから
子供の例で分かりやすいと思いますね
子供があの親に言われてね
まあ今日から自分一人で起きなさいよと
朝は言ったら 子供がはい
わかりましたと言って
目覚まし時計を持っていって
ちゃんと時間を合わせて
もう自分で寝て 朝ちゃんと自分一人で起きると
それ一回 二回 子供が一人勝手にやっちゃうと
まあもうちゃんと言うことを聞く子でしょうに
それ決して悪いことじゃないでしょうに
でもそちらにはちょっと裏があるんですね
そうやってこの他人が言うことをよくやると
子供が親が言ったことを早起きします
一人で起きましょうと言ったら
それ一人でやると親がものすごく喜ぶんですね
なんといういい子ですかと
そういうこと そういうとこがあるんですね
それで大人になっても
みんなそうやってよく人の話を聞く
よく人に仕事を頼んだらしっかりとやってあげる
ああいった通りにやってあげたと言って
あの あの 何て言いますか
メリットを思い存分いただく
ですから 結局 人の話にちゃんとやるんだということに重点を置いておく
置いているんじゃないんです
本人が無意識的にこのメリットに重心しているんです
重点を置いているんです
そこを騙し機能というのは
自分の性格は何ですかと
私はもう人の話をよく聞く
人が何か頼んだらちゃんとやってあげる
親が何か言ったらちゃんとする
そういう性格だと でも本人わからない
あれはメリットに充填しているんだと
だからそこら辺一つまた騙し機能なんです
だからこのばらしてあげることはできます
決してやっちゃいけないんですけどね
まあはっきり言うことですよ
それはあんたバカだからでしょ
逆らえないんだからね
人いうこと聞くでしょうと
あるいは褒めてくれるんだから
いい気になりたいんだからやっていることでしょうに
そんなことは誰も気にしませんよと言ったら
本人が必ず怒るはずなんです
本人がショックを受けちゃうんです
あるいは親が  そんな自分がね
親が言うことを通りにやったってもどうったことはないんだよと
親が褒めてあげなかったならば
ものすごく学習するんです
それでわかるんですね
これは偽善行為だと もし親がね
あんた一人で朝起きたんだからと言ってね
そんなことで褒めるわけにはいきませんよと
誰がそんなことで褒めるんですかと
言ったら子供が怒っちゃならば
もう子供はやっぱり褒めてもらいたいというメリットを狙っているんですね
そういうメリットを狙っていないならば
もう別に褒めてもらうか褒めてもらわないかということじゃなくて
正しいことを自分でやるという
子供にはそれは無理ですけど
大人にはできることでね
でも大人も結局はそういうことなんですね
このメリットを狙う 狙って良いことをする
そうすると欲が消えることはなく
なくならないんですね
で これはあの 仏教の人々のために書いているものだから
仏教という いわゆる出家の修行者のために書いているんだから
リストはいっぱいありますけど
ほとんど皆様に関係ない話ばっかりなんですけど
そういう人２ついますけど
ちょっと関係あるかもしれない
世の中でこの宗教に興味ある人がいるんですね
よくいます 宗教に興味がある
あれで素晴らしい人間ですかね
あれで素晴らしい人間だと
ちょっと言い切れません
騙されている可能性もあります
ですから それはどういうことかというと
大体世の中で金ばっかり考えている人よりは
もっと精神的なこと もっと心の関係あるものについて興味ある人々のことを褒めるんですね
尊敬するんです 世の中で
日本の社会ではいまだに
このあの あの人は フランシス・ザビエルですか
あのキリスト教を教えた人にいまだにすごい立派な先人として褒めているでしょうに
で なぜかというと その本人がすごい精神的な
このまあ自炊という方法の神父さんでしたけどね
私は褒めるべき人かどうかわかりませんだけど
まあ一応かなりこのアジアの方で先人として強引に作り立てた人なんですけど
実際歴史言った言っちゃうとよくないんだから
それはやめますけど とにかく我々に教えられている世界から見ると
かなり献身的で もう何も持てないで
自炊派だから すごい貧しい生活をしながら教えてあげると
すごい精神的な人々でしょ
そうすると一般の人々はなるほど
宗教っていうのは素晴らしいことだとと思っちゃうんですね
ですから 世の中でこの宗教家が褒められている
精神的な世界を目指している人々のことをみんな褒めている
尊敬している ああ なるほど
この道がいいんじゃと思って
自分もまあ金儲けることではなくて
やっぱり自分も精神的な世界に好きですよと言って
精神世界をにチャレンジする
でも結局精神世界にチャレンジするのは
精神の法を発見するためじゃないんです
本人わかってないんです
ただ 世の中で褒められているんだからなんです
ですから それも欲なんですね
ああいうふうに善人になりたいとかね
思って頑張っちゃうんです
だからどうしようもないんですけども
悪いともいいとも何も言えないんだけど
かなり複雑なんですけど
微妙なところで自分が欲を正当化しているんですね
ですから そういう人々は悟れないということを僕らは言いたいだけなんです
例えば お釈迦様がサーリプッタ尊者のことをものすごく褒めているんです
弟子の中で そこである出家者が
やっぱり私もサーリプッタ尊者のような生活をしましょうと思って
とことん仏教を勉強したり
サーリプッタ尊者のように徹底的な謙虚な生き方をしたりとかね
ものすごい謙虚で生きているとかことはあり得るんです
自分のモデルはサーリプッタ大尊者だよと
それまでは悪くはないんだけど
なんでサーリプッタ尊者に惹かれたんですかね
やっぱりお釈迦様さえ褒めた人やと
私もそのような人間にならなくちゃあかんかなと
あかんだよと思ったところで欲があるんですよ
そのかすかな欲が引っ掛けになって解脱を妨げちゃうんですね
ですから これはこのものすごい精神世界の優れている人にしか理解できない話なんです
今日喋っているのは 一般の人にとっては
そんなことでも頑張ってほしいんです
いろいろモデルを作って
あの人のように頑張るぞ
この人のように頑張るぞという状態から始めなくちゃいけないんです
でも進んだところで その欲も捨てないと
まあそれは欲のことで
それからこのまあ性的な欲がありますね
今言ったのはただ普通の欲のことで
それも悟らない限りは
性的な興味っていうのは体の中に残ってるんです
ですから残ってるんだけど
戒律で禁じられてるでしょうね
だから誰もそれをやろうとはしないんです
体の中には残ってます
ですから そのとこでもいろいろ
騙し機能が働く場合あるんです
性的な欲は良くないんですよ
良くないんだけど メッタ慈しみは良くないとお釈迦様おっしゃってないんです
それはいいことなんです
慈しみは別に メッターマイトリ友情だから
そこで出家者なんかは
まあ結構可愛い異性の方々を見ると
まあやっぱりお釈迦様は慈しみで接するんじゃいけないと言ったんだから
すごい優しい言葉でかける
喋る 優しくしてあげる
そしたらなんであんた人に優しいんですか？まあそれはまあ
人に優しくするっていうことは当たり前だから
本人わかってないのは
この人の美しさに自分が惹かれているんだということなんです
微妙なところで で 例えばみんなすごい可愛い人々で
だったら自分もすごい気持ちよく
優しい気持ちで まあメッターで友情で慈しみで接する
本人にとっては慈しみの行動なんですけど
裏にやっぱり異性に対する欲っていうのは働いちゃう
別にそれでもって懐柔とかするわけじゃない
そこまではいかないんです
ただ接するだけなんです
だから またそこら辺も
それは修行者がすごく気をつける
つけなくちゃいけないところなんです
だから皆様の世界ではね
そこまではないんだからね
皆様の世界でも人に優しくしますよと言ったら
大体可愛い人に優しいでしょ
可愛くない人には別にまああまり優しくないというか
無視するとか蹴飛ばしちゃうとかね
ありますから その人に優しくするのは認めます
実行もしていますよと言っても
それは可愛い人に限ると
ということに気がつかない
そこら辺は騙し機能なんです
それからメッターのカルナあるでしょ
カルナもカルナっていうのは跋扈ですね
人を助けてあげること
人を助けてあげることも
大変仏教では良いことなんですね
皆さんはそれを認めるでしょ
人を助けてあげなきゃいけないでしょ
自分でも人を助けてあげますよと言ってはやるんだけど
やっぱりまた可愛い人だけ助けてあげると
助けてあげる場合は 先に女の方に先に手が行くと
まだ他の 例えばおじいちゃんも私も助けてくれても
もう忙しいんだからね
おじいちゃん一人で頑張ってくださいと
おじいちゃんに見えるでしょ
私はこの人を助けているところだからと
だから本物のカルナっていうのは悩んでいる人を助けることなんです
男か女か調べることじゃないんです
たとえ美人の人がそこら辺にいても
体がもう泥に泥にまみれて
そこはいいんです 泥沼に落ちてる人を助けなくちゃいけないんです
だから騙されている人は
泥沼に何人かが落ちて
もうもがいていても あの上の泥
泥にまみれてる人はちょっと洗ってあげるんですね
なぜかというと これ可愛いんだから
服も汚れて もう障害なんてないんでしょうとかね
ですから 先に自分の手が可愛い方向に行ってしまっちゃうんですね
だからこの人を助ける場合も
みんな欲があるんですよ
気持ちのいい人を選ぶ
自分に気に入っている国を選ぶ
外国に行って援助するときでも
自分を褒めてくれる国を選ぶ
というふうなことになっちゃうんです
それもやっぱり欲が人を騙しているところなんです
もう一つ この人間は平等でしょうと言うでしょ
言うだけで誰もそれ認めてないんです
実際 私は世界一だと普通思っている
次に私の家族は一番いいと思っている
次に まあ私の村やらね
そうやって広げて まあ例えば自分の民族
日本の方々だったら日本人
日本人は世界で一番いいと
というのは普通なんで
そう思うことが あの平等やというのはただ嘘で
ただ口先で言ってるだけで
いくら平等だと唇を動かして言っても
人間というのは私が一番偉いということは思っているし
これどんどん見たら広げてみたっても
やっぱり私の家族 私の仲間
私の国 私の民族となるんです
もっと広くて見ちゃうと
私の宗教の世界ということにもなっちゃうんです
だからキリスト教の方々もみんな人間平等と言うんだけど
やっぱりそれでもキリスト教を信仰している人々が偉いと
という立場は消えません
だから 人間の平等という概念があくまでも偽善的でインチキなんです
そこで具体的な荒っぽい例でいうと
日本の時々ね 日本はもう現代社会だからとかね
今現代時代だから 情報化国際社会だから
まあ私はそういうふうに子供を育てていますよと
国際社会に合うように育てていますよと言って威張ってるんですが
自分の娘さんが黒人と仲良くすると
仲良くなっちゃって とにかく結婚するんだと言って家に連れてきたら
親が何言うんですかね
今まで語った平等の考え方も
今までかかった喋っていた国際的な思考も全部飛んじゃうんです
やめなさい あんた日本人がいないんですかと
大変なことになるんです
そこで娘さんがこう言うんです
お母さん何言うんだよ
今までね みんな人間同じだよと言っていたでしょうに
私はなんで私の気に入った人と結婚すれば何が悪いんですか？と
娘さんも反論する それで私が言いたいのはこういうこと
お母さんはいいんです
娘さんが人間平等だと思ってます？じゃないんです
ただ 自分に気に入ったんだから
その人と結婚したいんだから
平等の論を喋ってるだけで
その人のことを忘れられませんだから平等論を喋るんであって
本当は平等な人じゃないんです
ですから 自分の都合が良ければ人間平等だと上下関係ないんだという
都合が悪くなっちゃうと
それは認める また そういうふうにこの心は騙されてしまっちゃうんですね
どんな国でもよくあることで
本当は外国やら他の民族はもう馬鹿にしているので
心の中で馬鹿にしているんだけど
人を個人的に見たらあまりにも可愛くて
あまりにも立派で その時いきなり国際化になっちゃうんですね
やっぱり人間国際的でなければいけませんとかね
そういうふうに心は騙してしまうという機能があるんです
複雑ですけどね なかなか
3時まででしょうね 今日は何時まで？ 4時まで
4時までは喋れません
難しいんです あの たくさんリストありますけど
いろいろ選んでわかりやすいところだけ選んで選んで喋ります
そこであの ケチっていうのは良くないでしょ
気持ち悪いんですね ケチっていうことは
うん それで自分でも思っちゃうんですね
ケチは気持ち悪いんだと
思っちゃうんだだからケチにはなりたくないんですね
でも本当はケチなんです
ケチなんですけど これは気持ち悪いんだから認めたくない
そうするとこの騙し機能が働くんです
どうやって働くんですか？節約するんです
ケチじゃないんです それでやがて節約のプロになるんです
何でも節約と ゴミは宝物やと言って
かなりノウハウ テクニックまであって
人に指導するところにまで進んじゃうんです
だから どんなゴミでもどのように使えばいいかということをわかる
店で買うものはほとんどなくなっちゃうとかね
服でもいろんなもうボロになっちゃったら
こういう風に使います
それは使えなくなっちゃったら
こういう風に使いますよと
それでやがてもうこんなゴネになったら
それはもう肥料として使いますよと
服はね また違う服にするとかね
まあ雑巾に使うとかあるでしょうね
それで雑巾もやがてボロボロになって使えなくなっちゃうでしょうね
そうすると土と一緒に混ぜて
肥料に使いますよと そうやって考えてみればね
厳密にプロ中のプロでしょ
節約の 本当はケチなんです
だからケチであることは
そうやって節約という一言葉できれいに騙されちゃうんです
だからって節約悪いわけじゃないんです
ケチが悪いんです だから我々にそのノウハウがありますかね
これが節約であって ケチではありませんと
その区別できますかね
その区別できたならば大丈夫ですけど
区別できないんだから
やっぱり心は汚れたままで終わっちゃうんですね
それから  贅沢に溺れることもあまりよくないでしょ
食べたい放題食べて飲んだ
飲みたい放題飲んで 遊びたい放題遊んで
それで溺れる生活は良くないんですね
それ良くないと誰も知ってます
その場合は太っ腹になるんです
太っ腹というんですか
ありますね そういう言葉
まあ私なんか太っ腹だからね
まあまあまあ 食べましょう
食べましょうとかね 言って
もう何でも使いたい放題使う
そういう人生にしてしまっちゃうんです
だから本人が優しくて太っ腹で
みんなにもう分けてあげて食べてるようなつもりなんですけど
心の中はね 騙されてるんです
とにかくいろんな楽しみに溺れたいんですね
だから欲に溺れることが太っ腹というかっこいい言葉で騙されちゃう
そこらへん大体わかりやすいところなんですね
また このケチがまたある他の方法でも騙される時もあります
あの 自分がやっぱり貯金ばっかりしたい
何ももう使いたくないという悪い性格を持っていると
で そうするとこの仏教なんか聞くと
仏教で言うんですね あの
多欲は良くないんだと
小欲知足っていうのは善行為なんです
欲は少なくと それから自分を得たもので満足すると
そういうことだから 収入は月々 50万円のマンションでも住めるような
収入なんですけど 私が一人でなんでこんなバカでかいマンションに住む必要あるんですかと
そこら辺の木造アパートで人間っていうのは十分でしょ
地震にも対応するし この鉄筋コンクリートなんかちょっと信頼できませんだからね
それで 2万円払って あの普通の木造のアパートで一人住生活だからって生活
すごく満足しているんだと
ああいう生き方っていうのは
結局小欲知足ということじゃないんです
自分がお金使いたくないんですね
お金 お金使いたくない
ケチだ ケチだっていうことは
自分でも認めたくない
自分でも気持ち悪いんです
ですから これ 小欲知足という一言葉で
そこはペンキ塗って置いておくんですね
だからその人にはっきりとあんたケチだけですよと言っちゃうと
その人は必ず怒鳴るんです
必ず怒るんです 何言うんですか？と
あんた方はもう何考えてるんですか？と
私はこういう風に こういう風に
こういう風に考えて この木造アパートに住んでるんだよと
こんな大きな 50 万ぐらい家賃を払うマンションだったら
光熱費はどれぐらいかかるとあんた思ってますかと
それは私にお金を払えると思ったって
それは自然破壊ではないかとかね
これぐらいの家っていうのはもう 4人家族とかね
そこに住んだ方がいいでしょうとかね
そういう人々に住める場所もなくなって
私にお金あるんだからといって
そんな大きなところでね
過ごして あんた何考えてるんですか？と
だから私はこういう風にしているんだよと
えらい説教をします そうやって説教なんか返ってくると
もうわかっているもので
これはもうペンキ塗りなんですね
だからこの騙し機能なんです
はい まあそれからこのまた仏教では一つ善行為があります
私と違って このしゃべる場合は
できるだけ 少ない言葉で喋ってくださいと
あまり喋りすぎは良くないんだと
まあ本当は喋らない方が一番いいんです
喋るとあんまりも心が混乱する
感情が乱れる 相手が理解しないとどんどん自分が混乱する
で 途中で何を喋っているかもわからなくなっちゃう
思ってなかったものも言ってしまっちゃう
思ってはいなかったんだけど
一旦言ってしまっちゃったらもう終わりだからね
だからそういう危険いろいろあるんだから
お釈迦様は喋る時はちゃんと計量で測ってみて
やっぱりこれぐらい喋りますよと
20 CC ぐらい喋りますよとかね
20 CC 喋ってもいいところで
これあの 6000リットルぐらい喋ってしまっちゃいますからね
で それで時々人がいますね
言葉が少ない で 本人が
あまり喋らない人間だと自分に言い聞かせちゃうんです
私はやっぱり喋りすぎは嫌い
用がなければ私は喋りたくない
そういう人間だと なんか一見かっこそうに聞こえるでしょ
私は一応余計な言葉を喋れません
必要なものしか喋れません
それも用がなければ喋れません
だから私は言葉少ない人間ですとと言ったら
ああ なるほど なかなか立派なできた人だなと思われます
思われますけど よく調べると
その人の周りの人々とこの人機嫌が悪いんです
だから嫌な人だから喋りたくないんです
だから喋りたくないことをミタバハニという仏教の専門用語でごまかしちゃう
これミタバハニというんですけど
日本訳はわかりません
このいわゆる 言葉をちゃんとリミテッドというコントロールしてしゃべるという
うん 言葉少ないということなんですね
そういう善行為をしているんだと
まああの 例えば医者と患者の場合でも
患者さんがあんまりかわいくもかわいくもないし
もううるさいしね そうすると医者が言葉少ない
なんでどこですか？何ですかね
問題は 咳もあります はいはい
まあちょっと上 服を脱いでください
横になってください はい
この治療 この薬飲んでください
で 終わっちゃうんです
それで相手がかわいい女の人とかね
だったらどうです そうですね
この頃なんか流行ってるみたいですねとかね
こんな感じの病気とよくよくしゃべるんだから
その場合は じゃあまた来てねとかね
まあ医者のところにまた来てっていうのはとんでもない話なんですけど
平気で言うんですよ また来てねという医者のところに絶対行ってはいけません
だから その同じ医者は
もうおじいちゃんかおばあちゃんか
もう来たらもうすごい機嫌悪く
ほとんどしゃべれない
厳密に病気だけ ああ そうですか
咳もあります はい わかりました
じゃあこれ持って食べて飲んでください
ですから このただ言葉が少ないということだけで格好いいわけじゃなくて
自分がこのしゃべりたくない相手については
もう言葉が出てこない
出てこないことが この善行為として
自分が言葉が少ない人間だということにしてしまっちゃうんですね
なんか分かりやすいものを一つ
そこで人々のこういう性格があります
この大体人をけなすという
他人のことを褒めたくない
とにかくケチをつけちゃえ
つけるという性格 大体あるんですね
そんなもの普通ですよ
誰にでも やっぱり他人に対してはケチつけたいんですね
自分のことだったら もうとことん膨らまして膨らまして評価したいんですけど
でもそんなことを人に言っちゃうとね
人に言っちゃうととんでもないことになるんですね
そうすると 我々の心の中でこの騙す機能が働くんです
人のことを別にケチをつけてるわけじゃなくて
自分がこの悪いことをする人間が嫌ですよと
世の中でもう誰でもよくなんか悪いことしてるんだから嫌で
ただそれだけですよ 言って一生懸命ケチをつけちゃうんです
あの人どうですかね まあ立派だとみんな思ってるんだけど
でもこういうこういうふうな性格の人ですよ
だからもうそこら辺がなければとんでもなくいい人ですよとかね
そうやって この自分がこのただ単に悪を嫌いだと
不正的なことを嫌い ただそれだけですよと言いながら
他人にケチをつけるということをやっちゃうんです
それもいくらかわかりやすい例だと思いますけど
それから行儀があること
ちゃんと礼をすること
他人に対して素晴らしいことでしょう
挨拶することとかね それは素晴らしいことです
そうすると相手がすごく強い立場がある
人気がある 会社の社長
あるいは政治的な権力を持っている
あるいは凶暴な人 ヤクザとか怖い人
そういう人だったら 必ず先に挨拶をする
必ず礼をする 必ず行儀よく振る舞う
そういうことで自分が錯覚するんですね
自分がものすごくできている人間だと
相手に対して礼をする
すぐ自分で進んで挨拶をする
というふうなことを自分に言い返してはいるんだけど
本当は礼をした方が自分が得するんだと
自分の身の安全だというところを考えているんですね
例えば乱暴な人にしたっても
すぐ挨拶をして喋った方が自分の身の安全でしょうね
そこは認めないで ただ私は人に大変礼をする人間だよと自分で思ってしまうんですね
思ってしまって こういう行動をしちゃうんですね
もうもうもう 100 以上リストはありますけど
じゃあそこら辺でもう
出家者に言ってることで
例えばこの出家だから説法しなくちゃいけないんだ
在家の人々に で 一生懸命説法する
自分がそれは修行の一部だと思ったりする
自分が出家だから真面目に出家生活をしていなくちゃいけない
出家だからもうやっぱり説法しなくちゃいけないと
いで説法する もしかすると
その人の心の中で自分が裏
何て言いますか 人気者になってほしいというような気持ちが隠れている可能性はいくらでもあります
やっぱり上手に喋る人は社会を褒めるんだからね
あのお坊さんはよく説法してくれて
本当によく役に立ちますよと
っていうふうな立派な人が褒めるんだから
それは狙って説法している可能性もあります
ですから ただ説法している説法師ですよ
説法好きですよと言っただけで
立派なお坊さんだよということは言えないんです
心の中はわからない限りは
ですから 出家はそこら辺でも気をつける
もう私はやっぱり説法したい
私は説法したいという
そういう気持ちは良くないんですね
なんでしたいんですかと
人は聞きたくないんだから
ですから やっぱりその場合は聞きたくないのに喋るということで
やっぱりなんとか自分の立場が出てくる
自分の生きる道がそれで出てくる
みんなに認めてもらうというメリットがあるんですね
そのメリットを目指していると
それも一つの詐欺 詐欺じゃなくて騙される行為なんですね
それから人間の悪い性格がありまして
ものすごいこの 喋る 喋りすぎ
喋るわ喋るわ喋るわ喋るわ
どうしても止まらない
そういう性格の人々いますね
よくよく喋ると それは仏教で禁止しているんです
良くない性格だと それが知っているんでしょうし
それでも自分が精神的にはもう朝から晩まで喋りたいというこの苛立ちがあるんですね
いるでしょ 時々ぬいぐるみにまで喋るんだから
生きている人に喋って
それで気が済まない ぬいぐるみにまで喋る
一人でまででも喋る どちらにいても
いつでもその人の声だけはずっと続けて聞こえるとかね
このすごい喋りすぎ これは余計な話なんですけど
ものすごい喋りたくてたまらないという人にとって
私はすごいイジメをするんです
どういうイジメかというと
よく聞いてあげる  はい
よく聞いてあげると その人々はすっごく混乱するんです
だって喋りたいでしょうに
聞いてあげたら一番機嫌が良くなるはずでしょうに
それで逆なんですね よく聞いてあげると
ものすごいおかしい結果になるんです
なぜかというと 私の聞いてあげることっていうのは
こう 何て言いますか アイスと言うんですか？アイス地
え？それはしないんです
ああ そうですか ああ なるほどとかね
ああ それはその通りですねとかね
あんな言葉は使わない
じっと聞いてる そこでしゃべれなくなっちゃうんです
それで向こうは怒って
だってそうでしょ？と私に聞くんです
だってそうでしょうと
それは私に聞いたってもし
そちらがおっしゃった言葉でしょ
だからそれがそうかないかっていうのは
こと私に関係ないんですけどと
そうすると あったものはものすごいパニック状態になっちゃって
しゃべりすぎしゃべれなくなっちゃうんですね
で それ終わったら まあ用がなかったら私は電話切りますよで電話切ります
もう二度と帰ってこない
かけてこない で かなり便利なんです
だからそこは心の働きなんですけど
しゃべる好きなんですけど
ただ内容は持ってない
しゃべりたい話題持ってない
しゃべる手段持ってない
例えば話題があって コミュニケーションしなくちゃいけないことがあるんだったら
こういうことを報告しなくちゃいけないんだと
そういう人の言葉にも重みがあるんです
実は今日電話したのは
この報告したいことがございますと
そうするとこちらも何でしょうかと
言葉に重みがあるんですね
そうすると会話は成り立つんであり
それでポイントが終わったらお互い様
ではさようならと終わっちゃうでしょうに
ただ 病気でしゃべりすぎた人は
もういくらしゃべっても終わらないんですね
それで相手を相手があ
そうですね そういえばそうですねとか
そればっかり言い続けなくちゃいけないんですね
そこでみんな騙されちゃって
みんなああ そうですね
ああ そうですね ああ そうですね
そればっかり言ってるでしょうに
それで何時間でも時間無駄になっちゃうんです
だからこのアイスをすぐパッとやめてみたら
本当にポイントをしゃべってる人だったら
それでもしゃべるんです
ポイントない人とっといきなり混乱しちゃうんです
それはそれで置いておいて
このとにかくこの病気でしゃべりすぎ
人がしゃべりすぎという病気の人が出家したならばできないでしょ
しゃべることは 禁止しているんだから
そうすると しゃべるのは世間話はお釈迦様が禁止しているんだけど
説法しなさいととは命令しているんですね
それでじゃあだったら説法にすると
言って それから出家してから
まああることもないことも説法の形でしゃべるじゃん
それかえって同じ病気が現れただけなんですね
それも本人 自分を騙してるんです
自分がもうただ説法してるだけですよ
ただのしゃべりすぎということではないんだと
うん それはまあ 出家の世界で
えーと また面白い例 一つ一つないんでしょうかね
それからこの世間に合わせるということがあるでしょ
世の中の常識に 世の中のね
人々の道徳には 人間というのは合わせなくちゃいけない
それは仏教でも決まってます
法律は守らなくちゃいけない
その国のしきたり 習慣というのは破ってはいけないと
それから 民族ごとにいろんな変なことをやってますからね
日本人は日本人なりの変なことをやっているし
中国人は中国人なりにもう変なこと
くだらんことをやっているし
そうやってどんな民族にしても
まあくだらないことをやってます
でもその民族は自分やっていることはくだらないと思ってないんです
例えば中国の方々はお正月って２月だからなってくると
まあ爆竹は 1,000万ぐらいのやったりとかね
ドラと言わると音を出したり
太鼓を叩いたり もう骨まで響くんですね
あの音に 何やってるんですかとこっちが聞きたいんだけど
やっぱり中国人がすごい気持ちよく
お正月だからとやってます
これはもう静かな生活したい人間にとっては面白くないんですけど
そこで日本にしても すごい紳士な国やというんだけど
ほとんど半年だけでお祭りやってるでしょうに
みんなの前でなんであんな情けないみっともないことをしますかと
我々外人が思ったっても
日本人にとってはすごくそんなことじゃないしね
そうやって僕らの場合も
日本人から見ればいろいろ言われるものはあるんです
言わないんですけど 皆さんは発見しないと
ですから どんな民族にしたっても
自分の民族と民族性というものはあります
お釈迦様はそれは壊すなよと
だから壊しちゃったらね
この人々困るでしょうに
それ一つ 仏教の決まりなんですね
だから中国人のお正月の仕来りは壊せません
どうぞどうぞやってくださいと
その人々 それがなくなっちゃったら
ものすごく寂しくなっちゃうんですね
日本の方々も同じことで
あの現代の思考で言うと
くだらんと言ったっても
やっぱりその日にちになってくると
お祭りがないと何かどこかですごい不安に感じちゃうんでしょうに
ですから 人間のしきたり
文化 壊さないことは あの文化人として
仏教文化人として立派なことなんです
それでそこで騙される機能があるんですね
時々人々がいるんです
この自分には自信がない
あるいは人をおだてて自分の身の安全を図りたい
そういう人々はいるんです
出家した人々の中に で
それで自分から見れば
このやっていることは悪い
例えば日本の方々は酒を飲んでいるでしょうに
99% それで私が見て来てみたら
やっぱりみんな酒飲んでいる
みんなの機嫌を取らなきゃ
私には日本で生活できない
助けてくれない だったら
まあまあ それは日本の文化でみんな酒飲むんだからまあいいんじゃないんでしょうかと言って
私はそれを褒めてあげる
褒めてやるってことで
私はやっぱりお釈迦様は各文化のね
しきたり 決まりは守りなさい
守るように言ってるんだから
私は正しいことをしていますよと自分が威張っちゃうんです
でも本当はあるのは心の中で酒は悪いと言っちゃうとまずいんですね
自分の立場が 自分の立場がまずくなるんだだからそれを言わんことにする
言わんことにして そこをまた騙し機能で
それは文化を守ることだと
そうやってこの文化を守ることだと思って
ブッダの教えを誹謗する
ということがお坊さんたちがやる場合あります
それは単なる騙し機能やと
あなたは文化を守っているのではなくて
道徳誹謗しているだけですよと
ブッダの教えを誹謗しているだけですよと
自分にはご飯くれるんだから
信者さんがね その人々やっている悪いことは堂々と言えないんだと
悪いと言っちゃったらご飯くれないんだからと言って
あんた困りますよと という性格になっちゃうんですね
それも一つの騙し 皆様に関係ないんだけど
出家には大変な関係あることなんです
たくさんに まだ一応いろいろありますが
そこら辺で話をまああまりまとめないしね
すごいリストがあります
まあそういういろんなこの
良い顔をしていいことをしているつもりですが
心の中で密かに隠れて
悪い気持ちが機能する
そこが本人に気づかない
それがポイントなんです
本人が良いことをしているつもり
その機能がこの騙し機能というんです
私がいいことだと思ってやっているんだ
いえ そうじゃなくて はっきりといいことをしているんだと思うことがあるんですね
でも調べてみるとそうでもないと
ですから 特に怒りがね
人助けのように表れる可能性あるし
欲が人のことをよく心配している行為として表れる可能性あるし
例えばこういうこと 人に何かお金をあげなくちゃいけないんですね
その時は本当はあげたくない
ただ欲なんです それは隠すんです
本人がわからないとこう言うんですね
やっぱりお金をあげると言ったっても
いきなりあげちゃうと
それは良くないんだよと
あんた方はちゃんとそのお金の管理できますか？ちゃんとした計画がありますか？このお金入ったらあんた方悪くならないんでしょうか？と
あんた方にお金をあげるべきかないかとか
そこら辺もちゃんと調べなきゃね
なんでいきなりそんな風にお金を要求するんですかと
自分のことを自分で決めるのが一番正しいことでしょうとか
1 1 1 1 しゃべるんですね
説法する 頭で考える 寄付してくださいと言った途端
こちらではいはい わかりました
寄付しちゃうととんでもないことになるんだよと
だから寄付してくださいと言っただけで
私は寄付しませんと とことん説得して
とことん情報を出してくれなきゃ
計画書やら何から何まで出してくれなきゃ出せませんと言って
自分がすごくこの相手のことを心配しているように見えるんだけど
結果としてはあげないぐらいのことでしょうね
だから 本当に社会のために行動する人々が募金活動に行ったら
そうやって説教するでしょ
説教するでしょ 何のこの人はくれません
はい 隣の家に行きますよと
それだけのことなんですけど
でも本人がただケチってあげなかったということは知らないんですね
ですから あげたならばあげたで
私もいろいろ人にいろんなお金をあげたとか言われたことありますね
あんた よくもあれも知ってる
これも知ってるとふりをしているんだけど
あの人々はインチキでしょ
おそらく騙されてあげたのではないかと言われたことがあるんですね
私もこう言うんですね
あなたよりは私はあの連中はインチキだと知ってますよと
見ただけでも 喋り方でもなくてもね
私はそのどんな人間か知ってますよと
だったらなんであげたんですかと
それをあげたの それ私の個人的な行為ですよと
だから私はその人々にお金をあげたのは
その人々が普通に生活できるならば
普通に生活しますよと
でも普通に生活することもできない
仕事はやりたくてもない
だからボランティアやってるんだとかね
例えば地球にもない国の名前を言って
なんとか国に援助しているんですよとか
なんとか言って 最近までベトナムのなんのためにね
お金を集めていたんだから
私はあげるんです 聞いてもらったら
だから別にこのお金 ベトナムに行くか行かないか
私どうでもいいんです
知ってるのは  その人々がそれでご飯食べていたってもいいんじゃないんですかね
ですから そう言ったっても
あまり理解してくれなかったんだけど
ですから 相手がインチキかないか
詐欺かないかとか 調べて調べて調べて調べた上であげますよというと
結局はあげないということなんですね
あげないということは
自分が欲があるということなんですね
だから仏教で見ているのは
心の欲がなくす なくすかなくさないかというぐらいの話だから
相手のことじゃない 自分がお金を人にあげたら
その人はそのインチキであろうか
詐欺であろうが そのお金でなんとか幸せでいるでしょうに
それでいいんじゃないですか
それだけで それだけで別にね
だから調べる必要はないしね
あとで後悔する必要もないしね
騙されたとかね だったら最初からこの人言ってることは嘘やと
だからそれでもお金がないんだから来たんだからいくらであげますと
で それわかると 私の個人的なやり方は
まず相手に説明は断る
向こう側がいろいろ資料を持ってきて
またしゃべるでしょ 説得力ある
しゃべり私はいい しゃべらないでください
そう言われたっても これはいいですよ
それは私は読みませんだからね
ですから 用だけ言ってください
なんで来たんですか？と
来たのは私たちはこう
ちょっと待ってください
言わないでください 言ったでしょ
もうとっくに知ってる
これはもう詐欺やと ですから
あんた何のために来たんですか？と
向こうに頭に出てこなくて
結局あんたお金欲しいと来たでしょうし
募金しなさいと そうですけど
ではどれぐらいあげれば
1件としてはあなた方はどれぐらいだと希望していますか？ 1件当たりは
言うと答えられなくちゃあかんでしょうね
向こうは 私は資料は持って見てない
写真を見てない 何も見てない
説明もさせてない  1件当たりどれぐらい考えているんですか？というと
まあ大体日本語の円で言えばね
1,000円ぐらいとか
はい わかりました で  3,000円あげる
じゃあ持ってきてください
そうで またもういいやと
話は帰ってくださいと
だからそこは別にもともとも詐欺であることは知っているし
詐欺であろうがなかろうがどうでもいいことで
お金もらって それで食べて
なんとかもう幸せになるでしょうに
だから自分にとってはお金あげる機会ができただけ
で 周りにいる連中のは結構あげてるんだから
それでよく消えるということはないでしょうに
あげたってもキリがない
もっと欲しいとかかってくるしね
ああいう風に来る人が一回来たらまた二度と来ないし
ですから そのチャンスは生かすと
そういう風にあげるんだったらまあいいんですけど
普通はそうじゃなくて
なんでこの組織に寄付しなくちゃいけないんですか？とかね
あんた方はちゃんと NPOとして登録しているんでしょうか
ないかとかね 年間年会のちゃんとした
このなんて言いますか
このあれ 出費やら そういうレポートをちゃんと作っているんでしょうかとか
今までのどういう活動をしているんでしょうかとかね
それ調べて調べて調べて
さんざんいじめて どうにもならない場合は
じゃあ 500円あげますよということになるでしょうね
だから まともな組織だったら 500円もらいますけど
そのまともな組織は 2万円ぐらいの動力を使ってますね
その 500人のために
円のために だって 資料を渡したり
説明したり レポートを見せたり
自分たちの NGO 活動のことを説明したりとかね
それからまた あの日本で有名な方
黒柳さんでしたっけ 有名な方
いろいろボランティアなさってるでしょ
例えば そのような方があの
アフリカに行って あのパキスタンに行ってとか
ボランティア活動をするんだよと一言葉言ったら
さっとお金が入っちゃうんですね
あれは何でしょうかね
あれは決してアフリカの人々のことを心配してあげるお金じゃないんです
パキスタンの人のことを本当に心配してあげてるお金じゃないんです
黒柳さんが日本ですごい有名な人で
で みんな信頼しているんです
それでその人に接近できたというぐらいのことなんです
そちらがあるのは人気者にヒッチハイクしただけのことで
他の人にはあげませんと
それは知ってるね 人気者の人々をね
例えば音楽の人々とかね
たった 1時間で何億円も集まるでしょ
あの そうやって福祉のね
演奏会とかあるでしょうに
たった 1時間  2時間で
そういう有名な人々はもう何億円でも集めて集めて見せます
だから その何億円もお金を寄付した人々が
本当に欲を捨てて 慈しみであんなお布施したんですか？していないんです
ただ 世界一流の人気者にヒッチハイクでしょ
あれは だからあんまり徳はないんだと仏教を言うんですね
人気者と人と一緒に座ったらどれくらい天国に行けますかね
例えば黒柳さんと握手をしたんだと
それ天国に行けますか？だからみんなわかってないのは
この人気者にヒッチハイクしたんだからで
天国まで行けるってことじゃないんです
だからそこら辺もこの騙し機能を使ってるんで
決して黒柳さんが人を騙してるわけじゃないんです
彼女が自分の意思でボランティア活動をしているだけで
自分の能力を使って それにみんな大変心込めて寄付はします
でも調べてみちゃうと
その寄付にはなかなか徳のエネルギーは少ないんですね
ただヒッチハイクしただけだからね
そうやって世の中で我々の場合はこの騙し機能が働いているんだということを理解してください
そこら辺で この皆様に教義
あの意味あるところはそういうところではなくて
この騙し機能ではこの徳が弱いということなんです
良いことをしたら良い結果があります
でも この心に騙し機能が働いちゃうと
あまり良い結果が出てこないんですね
ですから この真剣に子供を育てたはずなのに
子供が不良になることはあるでしょ
あれはあの結果なんです
奥さんがよく言うでしょ
私は真剣に旦那に尽くしたのに
旦那が不倫しちゃったと
だったらこのこの騙し機能なんです
結果が悪かったらね 自分が騙し機能で生きていたんだということなんですね
残念なことは その時もう遅いんです
旦那が不倫して他の女の人のところに行ってしまった時
文句言うでしょ 私はずっと親切に尽くしてきたのに
私のことを裏切れて裏切ってしまったと
それで私にそんな話を言ったら
私は説明するでしょ あなたは本当は旦那様のことは親切ではなかったと
優しくなかったと あなたは自分のことしか考えてなかったと
お風呂を入れてもご飯作っても
あんたは自分のことしか考えてなかったと
だから旦那さんにとっては面白くなかったよと
ああ そういえばそうですねと
もう今気づいたってもう遅いんだからね
だから騙し機能の場合は
気づくともう遅いんです
だからどうしても騙されちゃう
必ず気をつけないとね
大変なことなんです 皆様にもありまして
それはだから皆様のあるんだけど
それはそんなに解決法はないしね
ですから この出家の場合と修行する場合はね
瞑想する場合は すごく気をつけないと正しく道は進めない
だからでしょう この宗教家
いきなり世の中を騙すのは
聖なる道歩んでるんだ
歩んでるんだと言いながら
どこかでものすごく権力のために
財産のために 行動しちゃうでしょ
凶暴的になって もう戦いにまで出ちゃうんですね
あのファルンゴンという宗教組織がありますね
中国では中国政府に対してものすごく攻撃かけてるんですね
我々は平和ばっかり喋ってるんだ
我々はただ修行してるだけだと言いながら
中国政府に対してはもう攻撃かけてるんですね
それからはもうはっきりとそういうことになっちゃうんです
騙し機能が働いてます
本人さえ知りません それは騙しだと
彼もブッダみたいですね
アメリカに生活してるんだけど
現代ブッダたちにアメリカでなきゃなんかあかんみたいね
ブッダたちいっぱいいるんですけど
まあ一応そういうことで話を終了させていただきます
どうも長い時間どうもありがとうございます